and he can start blitzing into all the  bad habit things  but so far  he's been doing well with the one  exception against nakamura where he  played these  two rash moves queen e4 and queen g4 but  wasn't punished for it let's see how it  goes today knight h4 what could black do  could take the pawn  or could move the bishop i guess takes  and  f3 is sort of a threat or the direct f3  maybe  well  um  maybe direct f3 because after knight f5  queen f5 f3 queen h5  at the same time we shouldn't forget  that the b7 pawn is also under attack  after  taking so  so let's look at some moves let's say b6  let's look at b6 okay just to try to  understand what is really  uh white's idea right  so can white really go in either five  between f5 f3  qh5  or immediately f3  yeah queen h5  it seems not so promising for white i  believe  i don't know if uh i mean h3 is not  something i'd like to play  no